this phone is by obsidian intelligence
group and it's a hardened Android phone
that uh has pretty much a lot of
functionality that you would get within
a laptop it is Linux but it's designed
for tablets and phones it's called
andrax and so you use this for in the
same way that you would use coli Linux
it's a distribution that's designed
specifically for kind of hacker tasks
but this also supports software defined
radio so it can do some of the similar
things that the flipper and the proxmark
and the hack rf2 but it's obviously a
little more stripped down version this
phone is just available like when I I go
anywhere internationally this is what I
use to tether my communications through
it has a static IP address that's
associated with it so it never changes I
use it to back haul data but it's very
very lock down version of Android and it
only supports secure Communications and
there's no like regular phone kind of
conversation it's all done you know
signal esque uh there's like 3cx and
signal
on